people who have the means to move around
used to talk about moving abroad if
things go south in America
we know we'll go to New Zealand
[Music]
but I do notice that that is that has
disappeared pretty much as a subject of
conversation so I think it's a sort of
recognition now of that if you don't
save it here
it's not saved anyway
I do think that it's obviously running
the the treadmill is running faster than
humans can run I'm worried about what
happens if America does put a pause on
on this because America might put a
pause on it you know Britain might put a
pause on it but other countries won't
but in the end you know you can't
can't actually hold back learning it is
the truth of it the entire thing the
lgbtqia plus the fact that there's more
and more people who are coming under
this particular it's not a real thing
it's [__]
total horseshit my view has always been
there's no such thing as a gay community
anyway that's just
that's just there is no bigger chasm in
the world than gay men and asexuals none
foreign
[Music]
do you like romantic novels no in my
Countryman who read romantic novels are
executed which is correct this is why we
don't have men with pink hair or women
with unshaved armpits what mate chill
out how about if the character was woke
even worse Lennon would have been
spinning his glass case but what if it's
satirical my country would do not have
satar laughing is not allowed if you
want humor
well if you were blessed with a sense of
humor and enjoy a bitingly funny
takedown of romance novels and World
culture then you have to read Daniel's
passion a new setup that follows a young
ivy league grad as she battles white
supremacy the patriarchy and late stage
capitalism in the hellscape that is
Irvine California this is not natural
live laugh and love to the eyes of one
of your more superiors suffer every
microaggression judge every co-worker
betray every family member as if you
were doing it yourself and come out
feeling just as smug this sounds like
almost Russia now I'm interested in this
book it's comedy done the right way no
lectures no messages no characters
banging on about the same Tire talking
points satire as it's meant to be solved
if you want good we'll go to Amazon and
click on link below we also recommend
you buy Thai moderates other books won't
fragility and a little book of woke
jokes click on Luke and laugh like
you're reading Warren fields hello and
welcome to trigonometry on the road from
the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest today is a prolific author and
journalist who returns to the show for
the hundredth time in about a year
Douglas Murray welcome back to
trigonometry
it's a little while since we spoke but
it is but you are one of our beloved
guests oh well your son my beloved host
thank you very much I actually told the
story on one of our raw shows the other
day about tricking you into our first
interview
how did that happen well we were at the
small conference in Oxford oh yeah of
course and you went out to the toilet
yeah and I was like oh it's Douglas
Murray I want to get Douglas on the show
so I went on Now's the Time now is the
time he's in the toilet he's vulnerable
he's vulnerable so I went outside and I
was sort of on my phone and when you
came out I was like oh Douglas by the
way and that's actually how how we did
our first interview and we have
interviewed you many times since so
we've talked about the standard culture
and all of that issue and you of course
have written about it extensively last
but The Madness of crowds and the one
the West your last two books
and of course the strange south of
Europe before that what are you thinking
now Douglas what are you thinking about
what are you seeing other than all all
the stuff that we all already know I
think the main thing that spirograph
preoccupying me at the moment is
um what we should be doing
um it's I'm working away on something at
the moment but the thing that started to
really preoccupy me is what would we be
doing if this crap wasn't in our way yes
um mainly in the hope that I know you
both share that that we can get it out
of the way you know
um uh what would we be creating what
would we be thinking about uh what are
the things that are out there that that
should be bothering us that that we can
address that we can make progress on uh
that that's really what sort of on my
mind most at the moment because I just
see this great clutter in front of
particularly young people that's what
really strikes me
um particularly in the US but it's the
same in Britain uh and everywhere else
in the in the developed world you just
have this clutter when you're growing up
now you always did but there's just
additional clutter
and I think for a lot of young people I
speak to are a lot of them just are
checking out the whole thing
as a result of that and I think that
we're at an enormous risk of losing the
talent of the Next Generation if we
don't
start to think really hard about how to
how the adults can clear the path and
what are you thinking there because I've
talked about the need for a positive
vision of the future and as you say
moving beyond woke and anti-work because
they're both destructive forces in terms
of the energy so what is what is the
constructive part where you know what is
that thing that we could be doing if we
weren't doing all of this well I mean
it's obviously different for everybody
uh
um I mean you know if you're a comedian
you make people laugh
um if uh you're a writer you write the
things you need to write
um I actually try very consciously I've
tried throughout my career to do this to
roughly balance what I write as doing
like stuff that I hate
and I'm attacking and stuff that I love
and I want to actually defend and write
about and and and do something with
it's very hard to get the proportions
right
and we all get caught on that first one
a bit too much I think but yeah writers
should write
um uh you know coders should code
um but the main thing is in innovation
in thinking and then coming up with new
ideas you know is
is there so much time spent on this
unwinnable game that we've spoken about
before the unwinnable game of
hierarchies of intersectioners and all
this stuff
and it hasn't yet got anyone anywhere
but imagine if that amazing amount of
energy and insight and ability was
actually directed onto something I mean
and people have their own answers as I
say when Elon musk's answer is you know
we should go to Mars and if you say to
Elon well why he'll say you know I think
we should have a reason to get up in the
morning mine is that I'd like to go to
Mars
that's not particularly my thing when I
get up in the morning I mean I'd be like
flip Larkin said about going to China I
wouldn't mind as long as I could come
back the same day but I but I
I just I admire him for instance one of
the reasons I admire him is I admire
somebody who realizes that you've got to
have a reason to get up in the morning
there has to be a vision it has to be
something you're going to do something
you're going to conquer
and
the other thing to say about that is
that the great temptation is to say
well the conditions aren't optimal
you know
there's this in my way there's that
there's the other and I'm not
discounting for a moment there are
problems any other problems of
young people are growing Capital that's
a big one we've talked about before
getting on the housing ladder owning
property
um uh all sorts of things a rewarding
investment rewarding savings rewarding
Prudence all sorts of things that
definitely could be addressed better but
I've become very fond of a
sermon that C.S Lewis gave at the
University Church in Oxford in the
Autumn of 1939 and I've quoted quite a
lot recently in speeches he said there
he says the conditions at the moment
aren't optimal
it's a great example of British
understatement yeah um but he says the
conditions at the moment are not optimal
but they never were he says human life
was always lived on the edge of a
precipice and if our ancestors had put
off the search for truth or beauty until
such a time as conditions were optimal
the search would never have begun
and that is a very important thing for
anyone who's watching particularly who's
young and starting off that's a very
important thing to realize
it wasn't always precisely like this but
in some general way it's always been
like this there's always been things in
your way
the question is whether or not you can
get over them Douglas isn't there
another thing here that all of us who
are attempting to chart a sane path
through this uh coming up against which
is part of the idea of liberalism was
throwing off the shackles of the shoulds
and the oughts right and we've now come
to a point where people like you and
people like us want to say there are
some things that you can do that will
generally speaking on average make your
life better right but we've lost the
vocabulary to be able to say it in a way
that that works and so we are now in a
position where we're afraid to say like
it's hard to say you know generally
speaking for most people family will be
a good thing yeah right but the moment
you say that then you're demonizing
people what about people who don't have
families what about women who can't have
babies and so on and any area of life
where you look at that is the position
we're now now in and that's why I think
we're struggling to articulate that
positive Vision because we're now all in
a position where we can't really see say
here's 10 things you can do to make your
life better and to contribute to society
because we're all worried about being
seen and being attacked for saying you
know this is what you should do oh you
want women back in the kitchen or you
want you know the gays back wherever the
gays were yeah all of that in the
bathroom
where they belong no
um yeah I I mean two observations
firstly
what do you describe about the state of
liberalism is something which John Gray
who I'm a sort of sometimes admirer of
um but he did write very fine essay some
music he's sort of one of the students
for Isaiah Berlin who uh maybe a success
or even to Berlin if Berlin had one
um he wrote a very important essay some
years ago now called modus vivendi about
the two different types of liberalism
slight play on Isaiah's two concepts of
Liberty but but the two ideas of
liberalism was firstly the the idea of
liberalism as an organizing principle
which organized it and then then left
people alone
the second form of liberalism is the
sort of rampaging always wanting to go
forward liberalism always seeking fights
always seeking a campaign as it were
and this is one of the problems of
describing liberalism apart from the
fact that it's a shape shifter term
many of us I certainly believe in that
first form of liberalism liberalism as a
as a as a wage construct and social
order and then you let people do their
thing uh the second form is the more
prevalent form at the moment it's always
the noisier form and it's the one that's
most tempting particularly to young
people because it says here's meaning
here's purpose yes
um so that's the first observation but
the second one um I think people just
got to be a lot less scared I mean I
don't mind saying you know look for
instance
all the data shows you're going to be
much happier in your life if you're
religious and a believer
I'm not able to be a believer a little
believer in religion
um but I don't mind acknowledging
that all the data shows that the
religious are more likely to be happy
why does that bother me
likewise uh I don't have kids
but I am not at all offended by the data
that shows that you know having children
is for most people the single most
important thing that will happen to them
in their lives is as you know
um
why does that why should why is that any
skin of my nose why should that
why should I mean I mean I'm not going
to construct the whole damn world around
my own feelings and that's what people
are trying to do and I think we should
be much less bothered by them so what
I'm not screwing up reality or altering
it or pretending to alter it just
because you might
be mildly upset about something so what
I'm mildly upset all the time I'm very
angry and irritable and much more Lots
but I don't think the answer to it is to
pretend that the world is not what it is
you know Douglas one thing that I found
very interesting recently is so for
example when I was growing up my mother
was Latin American we have a lot of gay
men in our family and
when I think about those men they would
they were tough they faced a lot of
prejudice they lived through the AIDS
epidemic they lost a lot of their
friends and their lovers and I'm looking
at this new movement coming in which is
trying to turn gay men into victims yeah
and I think it's the absolute worst way
to to live and to to identify sure of
course well living as a victim is always
disastrous I mean I wrote about that in
the war in the west using Nietzsche
carefully
um as I always say you have to it's
strong it's strong stuff I mean Nature's
great on the victimhood problem the
problem of of of of
victimhood is is I mean it's basically a
life that's not lived
um and it also encourages people to cry
about wounds they don't actually feel
um I I think you're right about that
there is a generational thing on this uh
you're right I can think of a lot of gay
men older than me who you know tough as
Nails because they had to be
um emotionally and sometimes physically
as well
um I think something like David Starkey
as he himself has said was sort of
created by the feeling of you know being
thrown into the back of a police van if
you were at a gay coffee shop on the
King's Road you know
um my generation was a bit more
fortunate than that uh but the one
that's underneath me is um is a bit more
whiny for sure
um I I mean you can always complain
about people younger than you uh it's a
perennial human pleasure but
I just say that I think some of those
people should have a bit more down
respect for their Elders
um but that's the case everywhere in the
western societies we've become very
weird societies and not respecting our
elders in any Community or Walk of Life
and that's very strange because it means
you're left only respecting youth but
young people don't know anything why
respect youth I mean it's it's worth um
recognizing the virtues of Youth but not
of worshiping them and I mean why would
you worship ignorance or why not look to
older people in your Society to help
convey wisdom and just doesn't seem to
be something that much bothers our
society we say oh look here's somebody
new and young and hot
let's see what they have to say
well that's like saying um you know
here's this old guy who knows a lot
let's get him to do a photo shoot
hmm
people make this this observation enough
and it's something that I have started
to say more and more it's deeply weird
oh yeah of course yeah of course it's
weird
you just noticed
but it but the entire thing the lgbtqia
plus the fact that there's more and more
people who are coming under this
particular it's not a real thing it's
[__]
total horseshit and I'm just one of
things that's very annoying in this era
is that there's these steaming piles of
horseshit in front of us all
and and we're all meant to sort of
shovel our way through them I just don't
have time and I might pay somebody else
to shovel the whole [__] for me but like
I just don't have time for this crap I
don't have time for people to keep
adding letters to I don't my view has
always been there's no such thing as a
gay community anyway and that's just the
gays lesbians and guys don't get on
famously have very little in common
uh both are very suspicious of bisexuals
have nothing to do with transgender
there is no bigger chasm in the world
than gay men and asexuals
none
like the idea that in a bar in a gay bar
like you know you'd be like hey your
heart I'm asexual
uh I don't know they have their own
hookup apps where they don't meet
um there's just nothing that keeps you
as far away from other people as
possible yeah exactly exactly and it
keeps people's clothes on yeah and and
then there's just then there's ones like
uh the queer one well Queer as far as I
can see is only I did a bit of this
amount of crowns but it only means
either ooh look at me I'm fascinating no
you're not you you dyed your hair purple
you're boring
um or it's
um
I'm straight but I want a bit of the
intersectional pie so I'll go like oh
I'm queer there was a guy I'd ask that
he was teaching who said that and he was
just like oh one of my students came
over and said it's so nice to see myself
represented you know by a lecturer and I
think this guy like painted his nails or
some crap like that and uh he he's a
straight guy he's married to a woman
oh you're doing a queer and queer used
to be an insult to gay people it still
is as an insult to gay people and then
it's appropriated by some straight guys
and girls because they think it'll make
them interesting find another way to be
interesting
um it's it's sort of grotes man the the
uh the uh the alphabet people stuff
doesn't really interest me I just you
know get on with their lives they bored
me enough you know but there's also the
fact as well that do you know and I've
spoken to quite a lot of gay men about
this and they all mutter under their
brush so they actually find it
profoundly irritating with the queer
thing where they go if you do blackface
that is seen as the most heinous form of
racism unless you're just introduced
unless you're just intrude on which case
it's method but um
but
that being the case if I come out and go
I'm queer and you know I've never even
had any form of sexual interaction with
a man that's fine yeah queer face is
fine yeah it was like it's like Woman
face it's fine yeah you can pretend to
be a woman and it's not insulting to
women
I don't agree I think it's very
insulting but I can't spend any more of
my life being upset by morons yeah just
uh particular attention seeking morons
look at me look at me yeah I've got
other things to do there's books I
haven't read yeah I mean that is a very
profound point but one of the things
that I really wanted to ask you Douglas
is you tackle some of the most
contentious issues the ones that a lot
of people simply won't go near
why do you do that
oh it's fun
uh and it's necessary
uh and I've probably got a predilection
for it uh I probably always was one of
those people who people say don't look
at that no look
at that type of child don't read that
I'll read it don't say that I said
um that's probably just a habit thing
but also the more you do it the more you
raise it's fine like it's not scary I
don't like I don't like the whininess
even of like the people who might be in
agreement with a lot of what I or you
say I don't like the whininess this sort
of self-pity of oh we should see what I
get on social media shut up it's boring
uh oh I got so much blow back from this
article but
don't spend time with your family your
friends stop reading
people you don't know on Twitter and I
just this is a general sort of boring
self-pity in the culture and part of it
comes from this sort of idea that if you
transgress certain
you know
I don't know certain dogmas of the time
that you're going to be put under a lot
of pressure some people are and I've
noted quite often that I seem to have
some inexplicable ability to get away
with things that a lot of people don't
and I noticed that my female friends in
the UK for instance who have tackled
certain issues I've tackled get a
horrible amount of of blowback and some
of them are not as
um cut out for it as you know as say I
am or some others including some female
writers are but
well you know okay each to their own
everyone knows their own limits but um I
don't I don't uh have any I don't have
any you know complaints about my life or
you know uh moaning Ted to be done I
have a great life but I say everything I
think is true
and um and enjoy it but surely when you
were writing about the strange step of
Europe and when you were commenting on
Islam you must have known this I mean
this is the most hot button out of all
the hot button issues yeah and it's not
all about Twitter blowback yeah that's
true that's true that that one is the
one yeah I'm being slightly flipping
because of the stuff I've done more
recently as well I mean I I think my
chances of being beheaded by a trans
person
quite small
I mean famous last words if I leave this
studio constant in
purple head
woman with a dick
decapitates me
please don't send that bid out yeah all
right we'll keep that we'll hold that
back but uh but I think I think chances
are low but yeah I think the chances of
a non-binary person like even being able
to lift the sword
exactly even making a run at me uh I I
think that's unlikely this one is always
was
um much harder I sort of feel like I
said everything I have to say about that
subject but that was definitely tricky
for quite a number of years in my life
yeah I mean it certainly made my
movements uh much restricted and um you
know a lot of my friends were sharp so
um it wasn't great but nevertheless I
think broadly speaking the point that a
small group of us in Europe wanted to
make which was that we still had the
right to blaspheme any religion I think
we actually sort of
we didn't entirely win it but we held
some kind of line
um it certainly could have been a lot
worse I think
um
and certain societies are more cowardly
than others I mean Britain is really
cowardly on the Islam one you know like
the the teach from Batley you know I
mean the whole damn government should
have come out for that guy every one of
the police and so on and the same within
it is into
mittens you know appearances of sort of
uh people who appear in places like
Bradford and stop films by thuggish
protests you know I don't think that
should be allowed and I have very strong
views on that I mean I simply think if
you don't understand our society get out
of it leave we're like we're not gonna
we're not losing anything not gonna lose
anything I think you should just go like
if you don't like a liberal modern
society leave it just go we don't want
you I think that's what government
should say I think that's what people
should say is you just you don't get the
point of being here fine scram find
somewhere where they don't show films
um so I I have no time for that but I'm
very struck by how weak the British
authorities are again and again they're
stronger in France uh and they're
stronger in certain other countries
they're a weird holdouts they're
stronger in Denmark for other reasons
you know but it differs from country to
Country
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
the thing that really brought it home to
me I don't know if you would have seen
the interview Richard Dawkins did with
Pierce Morgan
yeah and Richard Dawkins is a man I
think irrespective of his views on
religion some people really like them
some people don't if you're like me you
really like them and now less so over
time you change your mind but
he is a man who's been willing to speak
up and be controversial and say things
that people don't like and then you
watch that and you I mean look who knows
but I think the Assumption for many of
us is like this is a a very principal
decent man who very as he's getting on
in life
I thought that was a very sad
um I know Richard little
um I enormously admire him I mean he he
really is a man of principle and
sometimes you don't have to agree with
everyone's principle just to admire the
principle they're sticking to he's a man
of science so if he's asked to agree
that there are people with multiple
genders and sexuality Sexes or whatever
he'll just say no I'm a biologist or two
Sexes he doesn't mind doing that
quite Rylan but I was struck by the fact
that he
he didn't want to talk about Islam and
I've seen Richard at that Cliff face
some years ago he had a slight young
fortunate Fallout unfortunately I wish
it hadn't happened but he didn't
interview on Al Jazeera and I wrote a
piece slightly teasing him because he
had slightly stepped back from uh
criticizing Islam particularly Muhammad
and I I knew exactly what was happening
but I made a joke at his expense
um and it was quite a good joke if I say
so myself but it was a bit of a cheap
shot because I knew I knew the Chasm
which he was looking into at that moment
it happened to be on Al Jazeera and
um
I I I sort of I felt I felt I felt
that I'd made my point but I also should
have been more sympathetic to Richard's
own uh position at that time which is
that you know he didn't want his life to
be completely thrown into disarray by
becoming you know a public hate figure
number one for the world's Muslims
and um the fact that he now just said
I don't want to
do that I was a loss definitely
definitely
um but other people must pick up that
baton you know other younger people
they'll be they'll be new Young atheists
coming along you know smart
um they'll have been inspired by Richard
Dawkins and things he said before and
it's time you know I don't see why
or whatever Richard now is he should
continue to have to carry such a load I
don't think he should I think I think
people need to come along and share the
damn burden yeah that makes sense and
Douglas let's move on a little bit
because
um an issue I've never heard you comment
on and you may have nothing to say which
is fine I'll tell you if I don't I know
you will which is why I'm asking a lot
of people are starting to talk about Ai
and you I mean people will say you're a
political commentator but I think of you
more as a philosopher to a large extent
you think about society and and the ways
that it's changing and where it's going
do you have thoughts on what AI May mean
for Humanity
not many I mean I as you say I sort of
straddle both of those divides
um
that you just described I uh I've looked
into a certain amount I do think that uh
it's obviously running the the treadmill
is running faster than humans can run
and that's that's the problem the recent
letter signed by Elon and others uh uh
was a sign of that the one I'm worried
about frankly is
um
I'm worried about what happens if
America does put a pause on on this
because America might put a pause on it
you know Britain might put a pause on it
but other countries won't
I think there's a risk that it'll become
like stem cells you know like America
ends up like stopping certain research
here for for profound and
you know important moral reasons
but go to Central America and that's
happening all over the place
so my worry with the AI one is that
America and advanced democracies say
whoa
but you know China doesn't
um that that seems to me to be the worst
of all worlds is that the technology is
developed by by countries that are
already
um
not free to say the least
um but I don't know what to do about
that
[Music]
um
I don't know what the answer to that is
other than continuing carefully to do it
in our own societies
um but in the end you know you can't
can't actually hold back learning it is
the truth of it you know
um
I mean
it's it's like Guttenberg once it's out
you just can't hold it back you can't
stop the printing presses once they
start rolling
um you can't start the internet once
it's turned on
um
and again it's probably always been like
this you know
they probably felt the same when
gunpowder was first discovered
um
futility to to thinking about these
things
well not a futility because it's very
interesting but I think I think people
are misguided if they think that
that thinking about things like Ai and
being able to control them are the same
thing
um
I mean as I say I mean you can think
about gunpowder
but it doesn't win you any battles
um you can think about this discovery of
the Canon or the invention the the
automatic rifle
doesn't win you any battle
um we could think endlessly about the
nature of AI but I I think the
likelihood that you'll be able to stop
it is is is highly unlikely I think the
one thing that
I think the one thing that does worry me
about it and it's something which um
you know various philosophers have
talked about in recent decades is you
know there is there is a sort of moment
when
I mean arguably you could trace the
moment that we're currently in back to
that moment in what was it 1994 when
Gary Kasparov played the computer at
chess and lost
and the notes that uh Kasparov was um uh
making as he went along there was there
was a very striking note one of his
notes himself was he said the machine
isn't calculating its thinking
that's a very important moment in the
development of what we now call AI
um there's another observation on that
which um
which Tom stoppard wrote in his play the
hard problem about the Consciousness
problem it's very interesting profound
play he mentions that the only time that
he says that they were one of the
characters that's in the play something
I've always been fond of which is um
that the
the machines only really beat the humans
when the machine's mind losing
um because minding losing is such a huge
human Drive
uh wanting to win wanting to you know
come back
um
I think at this point the machines do
mind losing or very close to it
the one that
alarms me more is the issue of memory
and human memory because human memory
and machine memory are clearly different
things I mean I know this from our own
life spans already as a sort of weird uh
Gap from before the internet era it was
recently actually shown when Jerry Adams
of shin Fein Ira was back in the news
and somebody mentioned that on the
Wikipedia website for Jerry Adams the
only controversy under controversies is
um when he used the N word some years
ago in passing and got a lot of flack
for it I mean it's an explosive issue
Douglas
it's well said but but he's been
involved in more explosive issues in his
time and you would have thought that and
Mr Adams can sue me if he thinks I'm
wrong on this but you would have thought
that a man who was high up in an
organization which he's always denied
being a member of and an organization
that killed 1600 people and disappeared
mothers and buried their bodies after
torturing and shooting them in the back
of her head
should be on Wikipedia as a potential
controversy
my point is
not to get onto that hobby horse's mind
but my point is is that there is this
sort of Knowledge from before the
internet era which the internet is not
capable of holding it's the same with
the television archives
um there are things that like exist on
YouTube only because they exist on
YouTube and somebody's posted them but
there's all of this forgotten memory of
of what was before will the machines
ever be able to do the the things that
we have up here
maybe someday
but it will be different from Human
memory
um I don't relish the world in which the
machine can compete
with the greatest human mind
um because to my mind one of the things
that makes humans humans is
is having a sense of memory
um
Collective familial
and much more
and it also brings for the discussion
about AI art because I was talking with
Andrew Doyle about this and he said well
hey I can't create art because art is
the expression of the human soul but you
see everything that has been created
over it with AI and it's already so
Advanced that you think to yourself is
it going to make the artist obsolete
um I don't think that will happen
actually I mean study what we've what
has been produced so far doesn't fool me
at any rate
um uh it's it's a currently AI Artist as
far as I can see it are purely parasitic
art form
can only work off what's already there
so it can imitate and it can imitate
pretty well
um
it actually is quite easy to spot I
would say at the moment some people
watching will disagree and will download
send in examples that I couldn't but uh
I still think that if some but if AI
faked to Vermeer I would be able to tell
um I'd be able to tell the difference
between the fake and the real
um maybe partly because there are so few
vermeers that I would know but
um
certain artists might be easier to fake
than others
it's not hard to figure Warhol because
it wasn't hard to make
um
uh but will they be able to make
advances in perception
of the kind that say in the 20th century
Picasso and Francis Bacon imagined will
they be able to push forward the the
boundaries like that I
I doubt it I think it would be like in
music I mean in in in music almost
everything in film music for instance is
already imitative parasitic art AI can
create more of it but can AI create
Stravinsky
I doubt it
Douglas you mentioned Northern Ireland
and it's it's a niche question but yeah
I know you've written a book you wrote a
book one of your early books about it
and every time we talk about it I I know
I'm not saying it's not an issue people
shouldn't care about but you really care
about it yeah I I why is that I hate
murderers
it's a controversial controversial
position now I really I really I hate
murders I hate people who get away with
murder and I particularly mind and it's
a very straightforward one I have a
residual deep dislike of the fact that
the end of the conflict in Northern
Ireland consisted of rewarding
the people who shot people in the back
of the head for 30 years and then said
maybe we shouldn't
and sidelined
all the people who said from the
beginning don't shoot people in the back
of their head I really mean the way in
which
I mean on the more on the less actually
the the loyalist side was very very
violent and on the extremes itself but I
mean like Ian Paisley who had no no love
for at all
um Ian Paisley you know pushes out David
trim or far finer man than him
um Jerry Adams and Martin McGinnis push
out Hume and
um
that just always bothered me because I
thought the people who had always said
we shouldn't go down the path to hell
were all left on the sidewalk whilst the
people who were merrily walked everyone
through hell for 30 years came out the
other side pretending to be wise men of
peace and that that's always bothered me
and always will
um
uh I think it's just it's an injustice
which
still wrangles with me and I had lots of
friends involved in the conflict and uh
and I just know how many scars and
wounds are still there and unhealed do
you think that it was a necessary
Injustice in order to bring peace to the
region
it always depends whether or not you
want to reward violence you know
and I think we've rewarded violence it's
a very Niche view these days everyone
just sort of celebrates what they call
the men of Peace who are all the people
who were Men of War and then suddenly
men of Peace
um it's a niche point I would have done
it another way I would have continued to
[__] the IRA and make them come to
the negotiating table on their knees
which they very nearly were in the early
90s
uh
but I I'm
um I'm always struck by the fact that in
an era which talks about you know
equality and kindness and fairness and
all these sort of things fairness is is
is a much more important tangible thing
than the quality and all this sort of
things fairness is a very important
virtue and it was totally thrown out the
window in that and it's very very hard
for people
to see the people who killed their
families walking around I once was in um
Central Europe and spoke to a friend who
had written a book about a woman who had
been tortured and imprisoned in the
in the Communist era and one day she was
many years later after the fall of the
wall she was walking back with her
shopping and she saw her torture walking
towards her in the street you know
and if he apparently looked at her and
recognized her and he darted into a
courtyard
disappeared
but I mean it's unimaginable really and
and that for that that that in Northern
Ireland is happening admittedly for
people from all sides
thousands of thousands of people I think
at the very least people should have
empathy for that you know absolutely and
you spend a lot of time in the United
States I do and people are saying that
the United States is ever more divided
that you know the country is on its way
out and blah blah blah how do you see
this country Douglas it's obviously
divided and wildly divided and you you
can't unless you spend long periods of
time here you can't adjust how bad it is
one thing I would make observation on
that is in the time I've been coming
here myself I've noticed that um
uh people used to talk about people who
had the means to move around which is of
course not everybody
people you who have the means to move
around used to talk about moving abroad
if things go south in America
we know we'll go to New Zealand
it was a sort of dinner party
conversation if you like right what was
the other one Canada yeah remember that
yeah I mean none of these places have
made themselves remotely appealing in
the time since but I do notice that that
is that has disappeared pretty much as a
subject of conversation partly because
the way in which countries like
Australia New Zealand and Canada dealt
with lockdown and covert and showed
extraordinary authoritarian Tendencies
which most people hadn't expected
[Music]
um but it's also gone away because
what's happening in America is people
are moving within the country you know a
lot of my friends in California have
been moving to Texas particularly Austin
uh my friends in New York are mainly
left when I came here uh
um and they've moved to you know Houston
Miami and some of the wealth he wants to
move to Palm Beach or the West Palm
Beach and and you know Florida General
and some people see this as a terrible
sign an example of the further
fracturing of the society
um you can see it that way but you can
also see it as an expression of trust
nevertheless in the United States of
America or to put it another way the
recognition that if America goes south
you don't buy yourself any time in Malta
you know uh if America goes south you
don't actually buy yourself any time in
one of the countries that was
effectively protected as a satellite
part of the American era of of dominance
um so I think it's a sort of recognition
now of that if you don't save it here
it's not saved anywhere so you better
make sure it works here and and there
are people from the crazy extremes of
the left and the right in America most
recently on the right from the lunatic
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
who's the sort of gift that keeps on
giving for the Democrats
um who called for you know a split up of
the country uh
it's mad talk and frivolous talk really
but
um yeah it matters enormously that
people in America should be able to get
along and if they can't you know there
are many other problems that come from
that but I think that
I've said a lot whilst I've been here
that that people say so what one thing
can you do to to fix the the growing
divide and I always say you know just
agree on one thing
the one thing that happened I agree when
you were founded
you know or agree on
you know the availability of the
Constitution or just agree on the fact
the founding fathers of Great Men or
whatever you you want just like agree
that it was a good thing that Abraham
Lincoln was born you know whatever you
want just like or agree who won the last
election
that's a tougher one you know just that
would that would that would really help
in America because the problem as I said
quite often is that uh the problem is in
America in particular is not that people
have different opinions but they have
different facts and and you you find
very fast in any interaction in public
or private which facts the person you're
speaking to is God and the moment you
get into one of the ones they've got
which is one that you regard as not
being true
um you just get gnarled up
and you very rarely can get anywhere
after that you either have to park it
say okay let's just not do that now or
you have to go all in and you know
ruin the evenings
of a past Master yeah you know what when
you're talking about agreeing on
something all the things you listed are
important but I sort of feel it almost
goes deeper than that which is first and
foremost Americans and the West with
people in the Western countries
generally have to agree that we want the
West to survive like we want it to
prosper yeah and there's quite a lot of
people now who don't agree on that and
I'm not just talking about the crazies
on the left although that is primarily
coming from them but your point about
you know people saying we need a
national divorce all of that I mean part
of that is
a a an idea as you say is crazy talk
that would make sure that America
doesn't survive and doesn't prosper yeah
I mean the the problem is is that
everyone can only see the world from the
position they're standing in you know
and
um there's a limited amount extent which
you can say to people you have no idea
how good you've got it I mean you've
both spoken about this before and we've
spoken about it
you can sort of tell people it's sort of
Hell over there or is Hell there before
or is it but people are just living in
the lives they've
found themselves in and if things aren't
always going their way they will quite
often reach for a grandiose overarching
explanation for it
um I mean the Oddity of course is that
they tend to reach back for explanations
that have failed every time they've been
tried you know like I remember after the
financial crisis in OA there was a glass
of pieces by ignoramuses saying things
like
should we think about trying socialism
well as I should we look at
eating cyanide
but that's only because these original
people who think that there's a sort of
binary that's right which is like
capitalism when it's gone wrong like it
did in 2008.
the and the only other alternative to
capitalism is
state-run communism it's like that's so
again I I don't have much time for those
people uh and well maybe we should sort
of just ignore them you know uh they
just don't know what they're talking
about I mean you you can't open your
mouth and be that stupid I think you
should but this is what I'm getting at
though is I think more broadly in
society the very idea you know how often
do you hear on TV or in the paper
someone saying what you and I have both
said often which is the West is great
and we want it to survive and thrive
but that isn't something that people say
and I feel like quite a lot of people
don't actually have that Concept in mind
because they're so busy on the internal
fight they don't recognize that they're
external fights in which we are
weakening ourselves by fighting amongst
each other yeah I I I think it's partly
it goes back to the point I was making
about the mode as the vendy
um people don't necessarily understand
the settlement that they're living in
um
and that this might all be part of it or
at least this is the only system that
allows for that
um you know I mean
free market capitalism is the only
system anyone ever invented that makes
even its critics Rich you know
this is Mr Chomsky and others have found
out
um
uh Michael Moore is another good example
um but
I think a lot of people don't understand
the the the the mode in which the
society is set that allows for
self-criticism that allows for the
self-graduation that that allows for the
endless
criticisms and critiques and my view is
that that's all actually a a feature of
our society which is good
the self-criticism is a definite benefit
in Western societies it's good until it
turns into self-laceration self-loathing
and then self-destruction
and it's not hard to see where those
degradations occur
um but
I I think that yes a lot of people don't
understand
the setting they're in or laminess of
like the fishing water thing you know
they just they don't realize that that's
the water
and the alternatives are all just being
flung out into
a dry parched land I'm
um
but that maybe maybe this this stuff
only comes up because of sort of
frustrations that people are feeling and
and they grab for whatever there is that
they think is the only other
alternatives
unfortunately everything nearby that
they grab is so much worse as we all
know and one of the things that seems to
be a really contentious issue well not
really it is a very contentious issue
and we were talking about this last
night something that I think could
definitely
help to split this country up is the
issue of guns if the Democrats go after
the right to bear arms they won't
they weren't good
um you there are so many guns in this
country
yeah you can ever take them away
you just I just don't think it'll happen
well that was the nature of the
discussion we're having I don't say good
because I'm a massive fan of guns I just
know what would happen if they did and I
hope they're smart enough not to do that
people are um it's very funny all
societies have things about them which
uh are people from the outside just sort
of can't understand that's right yeah
and I always say that like in America
the two things that that Outsiders tend
not to understand particularly if
they're from Europe Britain uh abortion
and guns
and like the thing that Americans don't
understand about Britain is like
monarchy for instance obviously when the
queen died and it was very interesting
that you know a number of news anchors
and others said to me off off screen as
it were you know I admired her but I
don't quite understand the
intensity of this like what is it like
and I I found myself explaining to them
well well the queen is is like the
living embodiment of the flag in America
you know it's something like that and it
was interesting they sort of that they
got there but of course it's strange if
you don't live in a country where
there's a family and which inherits a
throne and a crown and deception and orb
and and all this it's so strange hard to
understand from outside if you're from a
constitutional republic but every
society's got stuff like that you know
franze his heart has Oddities that are
hard to explain unless you're French and
all societies like that and there's
always a slight problem when an outsider
as it were comes in and says I don't
like this thing it's it's an it's an
issue which in particular in America is
a problem in the south because the South
has
unfinished historical issues I was
touring around the Carolinas and
Virginia and other places recently and I
saw much of this firsthand that
um there's a sort of feeling of
bitterness that people from outside are
coming in and telling them what they can
and cannot venerate and and that's
my own view is that that's acceptable to
make those criticisms of it because it's
people in the same country but when you
have somebody come from I don't know
Britain and say I'm appalled seeing this
statue of general that you're not really
appalled it has nothing to do with you
um that that is the sort of thing that
people mind but that's the same in every
country
um but there is a tendency of people to
come to America and and blow themselves
up by saying I don't understand ex about
this society and the society says sorry
we didn't lay it on for you you know
when I campaigned against guns in
America I was a British guy telling
Americans how to lead their lies they
have 420 million guns we have hardly any
and so what do I really know about their
gun culture the truth is I thought I
knew better than them and shouted out
and louder and louder to try and get
them to give up guns and they sold more
and more guns because of my shouting so
the complete opposite effect to what I
thought we'd been driven out with guns
to get them Independence in the first
place who's this snotty British guy with
this British accent telling us what to
do I don't want to hear this from this
guy and I definitely don't want to hear
it from my accent it would be like an
American coming over here and saying I
want to bang Cricket because you know
people people get injured and what would
we do we said start off annoying
American go back to him you know that's
what we would think right so I broke
that sort of cultural rule
Douglas we've got to let you go because
you've got important things to do but
thank you for coming back on the show
very quickly before we head to our
locals for the questions from our
audience that only they will get to see
the answers to What's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we're relationship I forgot you
asked that oh you did I forgot I should
have prepared some wise answer seems to
me we're talking about most things other
than that thing I mentioned at the very
beginning which is what we should
actually be doing
you know I'd like I'd love us to get
onto that I'd love ambition to come back
is that what your next book is about
right
um no I um I'd love us to to really
focus
that's the truth and work out how to
unleash the real talent not the way we
talk about it at the moment unleashing
the talentless but unleashing real
talent or at least not keeping it down
um
yeah what would we be doing if we
weren't doing this crap you know it's
broadly speaking what I think Douglas
Murray thank you for coming back on
trigonometry it's a great pleasure join
us on locals we will ask you bonus
questions we'll see you there
the problems that afflict the West is it
irresponsible to have
[Music]
children
foreign